time now for another installment of our
series defending the first where we
expose the enemies of the First
Amendment free expression and free
thought high school teacher in
Brownsburg Indiana it's saying he was
forced to resign after he challenged the
district's policy on transgender
students that policy requires teachers
to address these students by their
preferred name instead of their birth
name teacher John Kluge says that that
violates both his religious beliefs and
its constitutional rights I recently
spoke to both mr. Kluge and his attorney
rah Stovall and I began by challenging
mr. Stovall on whether the school
district really violated his clients
rights you can't use the classroom for
for anything you want to do speech wise
I mean you are under contract with the
school so if someone who is a teacher of
anthropology suddenly wants to get up
and talk about his or her view on you
know Nazism or creationism example
that's my free speech right well yeah
okay but you're under contract with a
school to teach you know Spanish so you
can be fired for that correct right
right right well yeah to your point we
believe there's a constructive discharge
here that they unreasonably threw out an
accommodation that was in place they
actually had a written agreement with
John to allow John to actually express
his convictions by using only last names
of all the students that reasonable
accommodation was tossed out by the
administration after the school year he
was told he either resigns he follows
the line of the school using these
transgender names that were not as he
said the birth names or he will be
suspended and then terminated
those were the choices that's a Hobson's
choice so from the standpoint of our
legal position we believe we have a an
illegal discharge that's number one but
number two the issue the constitutional
issue is can the government compel him
to violate his religious beliefs there
is sufficient federal law that says that
they must make a reasonable
accommodation if he has religious
beliefs and those cases are really well
established
in the country we believe this is a new
one though because this deals with an
insidious effort by a governmental
entity if you will a school paid by
taxpayer funds so we see this as a
different wrinkle and we've seen before
in the cases coming up well the I think
the studies on transgenderism are very
difficult first of all there's no real
long you know peer-reviewed study that
we can look at with like whether hormone
blockers we don't need to get into that
so that's not really relevant here but
all I'll say is that there has been a
really explosive growth and in kids
calling themselves transgender and just
in this British study they went from I
think it's 94 referrals as gender
dysphoria as a technical term from 2009
to 2010 94 at this clinic to now between
2016 and 2017 1986 referrals including
some of those for children younger than
six years of age now a lot of people are
believing thinking that this could be
gender affirming treatments are actually
encourage kids call themselves
transgender most of them grow out of it
that's just the way it is most of them
grow out of it but also other studies
Adolescent Health Journal saying that
they are 2 to 3 times more likely to
suffer from depression suicide other
mental disorders very difficult so John
do you are you acting and part out of
concern for these kids thinking that
they're getting absolutely bad advice
and and from their parents or others I I
do really care about these students and
that is why I wanted to kind of sidestep
this whole whole issue I wanted to focus
on teaching the kids Orchestra on being
able to reach out to them and I have
been able to over the course of this
year cultivate friendly relationships
with my students and including these
transgender students of mine and I
really want to continue teaching there I
love these kids and I want to continue
that work John what was the reaction
from the other students they must have
heard of
that's what grade are we talking about
here 9 through 12 okay so what was the
reaction of the other students when this
student suddenly changed names in the
middle of the term well in my class
because I've been referring to students
by their last name only it hasn't really
been a topic that's been discussed we
focused on working together as a team
great create beautiful music and server
I think I've been successful in being
able to create a culture in my classroom
that they are respecting each other and
I expect them to and I and I care for
them and and II respect them all alright
and Ross the suit being filed in federal
court well we hope not we hope that the
school board at 6:30 on Monday recants
Alliance defending freedom brought me
into this as an allied attorney to try
to avoid lit we always try to avoid
litigation if we can get the AMA Dacians
handled we do that that's what John
wants that's what we want but if they
wants to go back and teach John wants to
go back and change and have his job
absolutely alright gentlemen thank you
so much